this is nico rosberg
star of formula one racing hard at work
he has a need for speed
and he's looking to clock the fastest
time all in a day's work for the 28 year
old german
but today there's a surprise waiting for
nico
his friend football star lucas padolski
has come to the nurburgring to get a
taste of motor racing
formula one style
in just 4.3 seconds the c63 amg hits the
100 kilometer per hour mark as it heads
out on the legendary north loop track
for lucas it's an adrenaline kick of a
new kind
uh here that's what it's checking here
the c63 amg's road ability is of course
quite different from nico's formula one
car
but it still boasts impressive stats a
maximum
output of 358 kilowatts means everyone's
firmly fixed
in their seats
lucas asked whether niko has to break
hard in this formula one mercedes
nico says oh yeah
time to change places he's got his lucky
shirt on
and now lucas takes the driver's seat
nico's request lucas promises to give it
his all
and he puts his foot right down
nico jokes that lucas could go even
faster on the next curve
but then he has to admit that he's not
the most relaxed passenger
he's been breaking the whole time with
his left foot
nico has passed his first test intact
and now it's on to the next one teammate
lewis hamilton is getting ready for
nico's next challenge
and he's brought along some true racing
legends to do it
these two iconic silver arrows have
returned to the north loop
nico and lewis are going to show how
today's formula 1 stars handle the cars
driven by the racing heroes of
yesteryear
the outdated technology doesn't seem to
hinder either driver
and neither appears worried that the
cars they're driving have a present day
value of several million euros
lewis hamilton is in the older car
marked number two
75 years ago in 1938 britain richard
seaman
won the german grand prix in the w154 at
the nurburgring
16 years later in 1954 argentinian
racing legend juan manuel fangio won the
race
in the eiffel and the w196
and just like today's grand prix the
races drew hundreds of thousands of
spectators
foreign
the 1938 german grand prix was to be a
double victory for mercedes-benz
driving the silver arrows today is
something special for our modern racers
you certainly can't get closer to
history than this
nico says it's great fun to drive the
silver era
but back in the old days there was a
great deal of risk involved in racing
it's incredible to think of the cars
going full throttle on the racing track
and pouring rain without any barriers
between the trees
nico says it's an honor to have driven
the car that fangio won in
it's really great
breaking was a bit of a problem he says
that with the clutch it was tough to
really get a feel for the brakes and the
gears
the car is after all unique
the experience has left an impression on
lewis too
i can't imagine what it was like back
then racing these cars even though i've
done a lap now
um but it's pretty phenomenal what they
did
yeah well the accelerator is in the
middle and the breakers on the right and
then the clutch is on the left
so going down the hill sometimes i was
looking for the brake and couldn't find
it
trying to get into gear is the hardest
thing it doesn't want to go into gear
ever
so it almost stalls each time i was
trying to put it into gear and then you
eventually
crank it into gear but maybe i wasn't
aggressive enough i think i was too
gentle with it
these old-school racing cars may look
tinny but they're far from being
consigned to the scrap heap
our young stars have shown that the
silver arrows are still worthy of
respect as true makers of racing history
you